[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض هذه ابرز عناوينها
نزاع السودان مستمر محادثات بين طرفي
النزاع في جده والسعوديه تطلق حمله اغاثيه
وللعاده السعوديه يلتقي مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكيه اليمن على راس الملفات
وفقا للبيت الابيض
غياب الاستثمارات عن شواطئ الشرقيه تثير
التساؤلات شاطئ الاطول على سواحل الخليج
العربي
وفي الرابعه ايضا
مكه تتنفس مساحات كبيره من حي الكدوه تودع
العشوائيات وتستعد لمراحل التطوير
وضمن مهرجان افلام السعوديه في المنيوثق
رحله الصحفيه السعودي الراحل تركي سديري
بحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان لو ضاع في السودان في اتصال
هاتفي مع مسؤول السياسات الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل وحسب وكاله
الانباء السعوديه ناقش الاتصال مستجدات
المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه الخاصه
بالسودان والتي تهدف لتهيئه الارضيه
اللازمه للحوار من اجل خفض مستوى التوترات
24 يوما مرت على اندلاع الاشتباكات في
السودان هدن شكليه وجهود سياسيه لحل
الازمه اخرها محادثات جد التي تستمر لليوم
الثالث بين طرفين نزاع برعايه سعوديه
امريكيه والتي تهدف لوضع حد للمواجهات
وايجاد خطط لوقف اطلاق نار
اسبوع رابع ينتصف من مواجهه السودان الذي
يمضي في طريق العوده نحو 500 مدنيين على
الاقل ذهبوا ضحيه النزاع المسلح فضلا عن
الاف المصابين واعداد اكبر للنازحين هنا
في جده تستمر المحادثه التمهيديه بين
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوه الدعم
السريع برعايه سعوديه امريكيه الخارجيه
السعوديه اكدت ان طرفي النزاع اعرب عن
تحملهما مسؤوليه وصول المساعده الانسانيه
العاجله واستعاده الخدمات الضروريه في
السودان كما شرع الطرفان في مراجعه اعلان
الالتزام بحمايه المدنيين وتيسير واحترام
العمل الانساني
وتسعى محادثات جده الى وضع جدول زمني
لمفاوضات موسعه للوصول لوقف دائم للاعمال
القتاليه كما دعت الرياض و واشنطن طرفي
النزاع في السودان الى احترام وقف اطلاق
النار حاليا والامتناع عن القيام باي
افعال استفزازيه تؤثر على سير المحادثات
محادثات في جده واجتماع عربي طارئ في
القاهره نتج عنه انشاء لجنه اتصال عربيه
لوقف النار في السودان تتكون من وزير
الخارجيه السعودي ونظره المصري والامين
العام للجامعه العربيه
جهود سياسيه للتهدئه تقابلها تحركات
انسانيه وحملات اجلاء مستمره تبنتها
السعوديه اخرها تقديم مساعدات انسانيه
متنوعه بقيمه 100 مليون دولار واطلاق حمله
شعبيه
لمسانده الشعب السوداني
يضم لينا المشرف العام على مركز الملك
سلمان لغات الدكتور عبد الله ربيع دكتور
عبد الله حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
نريد فقط ان نشير الى ان هذه الحمله حمله
جمع التبرعات للحمل الشعبيه السودانيه
لغاته الشعب السوداني انطلقت تقريبا قبل
ساعتين او ثلاث وبلغ مجموعها اكثر من حتى
الان يعني وصلت الى اكثر من 340 انتظار
التحديثات في هذه الارقام دكتور
اولا تقييمكم الاول لحجم الاثر الانساني
جراء هذه الحرب التي تعيشها السودان اليوم
مرحبا خالد ومرحبا بمشاهد العربيه بلا شك
ان السوداني يعاني من تحديات كبيره قبل
بدء هذه الاحداث بوضع انساني ليس جيد
وجاءت هذه الاحداث التي تضاعف الاحتياج
الانساني حسب التقديرات الاوليه هنالك
اكثر من 15 مليون
سوداني بحاجه الى دعم انساني سواء كان في
مجال التغذيه او الصحه او الايواء اكثر من
300 الف نجحوا بسبب هذه الاحداث التي حصلت
في السودان
وكذلك الاوضاع الصحيه كانت هشه قبل
الاحداث وازدادت خشبيه بسبب هذه
اذا جاءت توجيهات خالد محرمين الشريف
بدعم سخي من الدوله حفظها الله بمئه مليون
دولار وكذلك كما اشرت اخي خالد باطلاق
حمله تبرعات شعبيه لغاته الشعب السوداني
الشقيق عبر منصه ساهم والتي من خلال قناه
العربيه ندعو رجال الاعمال والمحسنين
والمتبرعين بالمساهم الفاعله
لتخفيف معاناه الشعب السوداني الشقيق ما
هي الخطه المعتمده من قبل المركز
لنقل هذه المساعدات الى ايصالها كيف سيتم
توزيعها ايضا بعد دخولها الى السودان
هناك
الان
خطه
الى السودان وكذلك نقل مواد اخرى عبر
البحر من خلال جسر بحري كذلك تم التواصل
سواء مع المنظمات الدوليه او المنظمات
المحليه للعمل في السودان ونقلها الى اكثر
احتياجا المناطق الاكثر احتياجا وهي كما
اشرتم في قناه العربيه هي مناطق الجزيره
هو كردفان ودار وسنار
وكذلك سوف يكون هنالك
عاملين على الارض من منسوب مركز الملك
سلمان الانسانيه
للمساهمه في وصول هذه المساعدات ونامل
باذن الله عند استقرار الوضع سوف كذلك
تشارك الفرق التطوعيه سواء الصحيه او
غيرها
لاجراءات صحيه لتخفيف المعاناه الصحيه لدى
المحتاجين الجسر الجوي متى سينطلق
يعتمد على حصول التصاريح اللازمه نحن
جاهزون لكن نعمل على حصول التصاريح
الجاهزه ان يكون هناك تنسيق بين طرفي
الصراع او ماذا دكتور
انا اعتقد انه تنسيق مع المنظمات المحليه
وضمان وصول هذه المساعدات دون اي تدخل
خارجي من اطراف النزال هل يجري الاتصال
والتنسيق مع طرفي النزاع يعني اللي هم من
يتسارع اليوم على الارض يعني في مناطق
متعدده من السودان دكتور
تاكد من خلاله وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
هنالك
اول ضمان مامونيه
الوصول الانساني وتامين سواء كان النقل
الجوي او البحري او كذلك البري داخل
السودان من المهم يا اخي خالد ان ليس فقط
ان تصل الى الميناء او الى المطار الاهم
هو وصولها عبر الحافلات البريه الى ذوي
الاحتياج الاعلى لذلك هنالك تواصل على
مستوى عالي من وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
لضمان مامونيه وصول هذه المساعدات بالشكل
الاسرع والامل
الاولويه للولايات الاكثر تاثرا اللي
ذكرتها النيل الازرق ولايه البحر الاحمر
شمال دارفور هذا حتى حسب تقديرات الامم
المتحده الاخيره ليس كذلك دكتور جيد
وكذلك تقديرات مركز الملك سلمان كما تعلم
لدينا
منظمات محليه نتعامل معها وتواصل مستمر
ونتفق مع ما ذكرته منظمات المتحده ان هذه
الم الاكثر احتياجا في السودان في هذه
الايام خاصه هناك يعني مشاكل تتعلق
بمناطق مراكز الرعايه الصحيه يعني وغيرها
ايضا هل هي مشموله
الخرطوم العاصمه
صحيح الخرطوم العاصمه والناجحون لجنوب
العاصمه الخرطوم هنالك خطه لدعم القطاع
الصحي
بما يضمن تامين العلاج اللازم لذوي
الاحتياج من سيتولى التامين الافراد افراد
المركز دكتور
العاملين على الارض
نعمل مع اولا المنظمات الامميه والمنظمات
المحليه وكذلك كما اشرت هنالك تواصل على
مستوى العالم لضمان مامونيه العاملين من
منسوب المركز
وسوف نتاكد ان منسوب المركز يذهبون
للمناطق الاكثر امانا في الجنوب التي نجح
عليها
النازحون من الخرطوم والمناطق المجاوره
لها الخطه ستكون على شكل مراحل المرحله
الاولى يعني حسب المعلومات الاوليه ستكون
على شكل مراحل المرحله الاولى ستركز على
الادويه على الغذاء
الحجم الذي يحتاجه الان وبالتالي ماذا عن
المراحل الاخرى التاليه
طبعا
[موسيقى]
النازحين ويتبعها كذلك مرحله دعم المرافق
الصحيه بما يضمن عودتها الى عملها الكامل
ثم كذلك يتبعها الى
دعم
المدن الشماليه التي فيها احتياج كذلك اخر
والمرحله
لها اثناء وجود
استقرار مدن الرئيسيه سوف تبدا الحملات
الطبيه التطوعيه التي سوف تساهم في اجراء
الجراحات والاجراءات الطبيه اللازمه من
قبل الكوادر السعوديه المستقبل اتمنى لكم
التوفيق شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور عبد الله
الربيع المشرف العام على مركز الملك سلمان
ونبقى في تطورات الازمه السودانيه وبعد
زيارته الى القاهره وصل السفير دفع الله
الحاج علي مبعوث رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان الى جوبا
عاصمه جنوب السودان دفع الله الحاج قال ان
زيارته الى جوبا في اطار التوضيح اخر
مستجدات الازمه الجاريه في الخرطوم وسبل
تعزيز العلاقه بين البلدين في هذه المرحله
وصلت الان
مبعوثا من السيد رئيس مجلس السياده
الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
لابلغ رساله لشقيقه الرئيس جمهوريه جنوب
السودان السيد الرئيس سلفكير
ساقدم له شرحا وافيا لاخر تطورات الازمه
في السودان سنتناول
اسس
وسبل تعزيز التعاون في هذه المرحله لما
يربط بيننا بلدينا الشقيقين من اواصر قويه
استقبل ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان مساء احد مستشاره الامن القوميه
الامريكي جاك سولفان وتم خلال اللقاء
استعراض العلاقات الاستراتيجيه بين
البلدين وسبلت عزيزها في مختلف المجالات
كما تم ايضا استعراض مستجدات الاوضاع
الاقليميه والدوليه ذات الاهتمام المشترك
وكشف البيت الابيض في بيانيا استعرض مع
الامير محمد بن سلمان التقدم الكبير
لتعزيز الهدنه في اليمن اضافه الى قضايا
اقليميه اخرى رجاء مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي شكر لولي العهد السعودي على
الدعم الذي قدمته السعوديه للمواطنين
الامريكيين اثناء اجلائهم من السودان وفقا
للبيان كما استقبل ولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان نائبه حاكمي ابوظبي مستشار الامن
الوطني في دوله الامارات ومستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي ومستشار الامن القومي
الهندي وبحث اللقاء سبلة تعزيز العلاقات
والروابط بين دولهم بما يعزز النمو
والاستقرار في المنطقه
ينضم الينا خبير السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه الدكتور وليد فارس دكتور وليد
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابع ما هي اهداف
واشنطن من هذه الزياره في هذا التوقيت
دون شك هذه الاهداف باتت واضحه يوما بعد
يوم واشنطن تستعد لاعاده التموضع بعد
التغييرات السياسيه التي عصفت في المنطقه
وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالاتفاق السعودي
الايراني ولكن ليس هذا هو على الطاوله ما
هو على الطاوله بالنسبه لواشنطن الان هو
محاوله حل الازمه في السودان محاوله الحد
من انتشارها داخل السودان وبالطبع لا يخفى
على احد انه هذه الازمه تشكل مشكله
استراتيجيه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ليس للاسباب الداخليه فقط في السودان ولكن
ايضا على الصعيد الاقليمي والدوري مع وجود
مجموعات ذات تاثير من روسيا وغير اماكن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي الان موقع
الحل وبالتالي هذه الزياره هدفها الاول هو
التواصل مع القياده السعوديه هناك تسريبات
من من اكثر من موقع وصحيفه ايضا امريكيه
تحدثت على ان جاك سلفن ياتي بطريقه حرير
امريكي جديد يعني
ليكون بديلا لطريق الحرير الصيني في
المنطقه الى اي مدى يمكن ان ينجح سليمان
او تنجح واشنطن في اقناع الرياض بهذا
البديل نتحدث عن الهند كبديل استراتيجي
للصين كما اتت هذه التكهنات يعني
هنالك كلام كثير في واشنطن وفي كل
الاتجاهات وحسب اي وسيله اعلاميه الى ما
هنالك الواقع الذي اراه انا هو انه في خضم
الانقسام العميق السياسي في واشنطن بين
الكونجرس خاصه مجلس النواب والاداره هنالك
من يتهم او ينتقد الاداره بانها اخفقت في
ملفات كثيره بما فيها العلاقات مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والتحالف العربي البعض
الاخر ينتقد توتر العلاقات مع اسرائيل
والان بالطبع مع هذه الازمه في السودان
البعض ينتقد الاداء السلبي على الاقل او
غير الناجح للاداره لمواجهه ذلك تتحرك
الاداره وبوضوح للعوده الى فتح هذا الخط
الحريري او الخط الذهبي الجديد مع المملكه
لاقناعها بان تلعب دورا كما تلعبه الان
ولكن ان تبين انه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اصدقاء وحلفاء لانه المعارضه في
واشنطن تفهم الاداره بانها تخلت عن
خلفائها لم يعد هنالك حلفاء في المنطقه
يثقون بهذه السي هذا رد على هذا الانتقاد
وفعلا رئيس بايدن وفريقه يريدون اعاده
تحسين العلاقات خاصه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هذه الزياره ايضا كان فيها
طرف اماراتي طرف كذلك هندي موجود في هذه
الزياره وفي هذه المباحثات بالاضافه الى
سليمان
وهم اتحدث عن يعني الامارات والهند اعضاء
في منظمه
هذه المنظمه هل يمكن بالفعل
ماذا تريد امريكا منها ان تكون بديلا
بديلا للصين بديلا لشانغهاي بديلاكس ام
رديفا لها تريد يعني المشاركه ماذا تريد
امريكا بالنظر حتى للتحديات الخطيره التي
تمثلها الصين يعني على امريكا والنظام
العالمي من وجهه نظر واشنطن
في بدايه هذا الحديث تكلمت عن التغييرات
الكبيره الصاعقه الى حد ما بالنسبه
لواشنطن عندما جرت كل هذه الاتفاقات
والجميع هنا يعرف ان الصين هي تحسنت من
تموقعها اصبحت هي الضامن لهذه الاتفاقات
بين ايران والسعوديه وقد يكون هنالك ملاحق
لهذا الموضوع ولان الرياض هي الضامن او
تحاول ان تكون الضامن والحكم ما بين
الاطراف السودانيه دور المملكه انتقل من
حليف عادي او شريك عادي للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى صانع قرار يعني المملكه
بامكانها ان تتكلم مع الصين مع الهند مع
روسيا ومع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وان
تكون لها عقود مع كل هذه الاطراف هذا غير
الموقف لذلك اداره بيضا على الاقل تتكل
على المملكه وتحاول ان تقنعها عمليا بانها
تريد علاقات خاصه ومميزه كالتي عندها يعني
مع اسرائيل الى حد ما هذا لانه الوضع في
الشرقي الاوسط يتغير بسرعه تفوق سرعه
الامريكي فهذه محاوله للحاق بما يجري في
للحاق يوضعها كبديل يعني لطرد الصينيين من
المنطقه لما تمثله من اهميه استراتيجيه
الان في في طبيعه النظام والعلاقات
الدوليه دكتور فارس ام رديف
واقعيا استاذ خالد واقعيا جميع يعرف او
معظم الناس تعرف انه لا يمكن طرد الصين
يعني العمل الذي ادى الى دخول الصين الى
هذه المنطقه الخليج والهلال الخصيب وربما
دول اخرى في افريقيا هذا يعني كان له
تحضيرات وتهيئات منذ بسبب
نعم وبسبب الخروج الى امريكا ربما كذلك من
المنطقه تغيير السياسه الامريكيه التي
ركزت كل شيء على اتفاق نووي الايراني
وتناصت كل
شيء الى هذا الاتفاق هذا هو الثمن يعني
هذا هو الثمن الان تراه واشنطن ونفس الشيء
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا وروسيا كان بامكان هذا
الاداره ان تتصرف بشكل اخر لكي تحد من هذه
الحرب ولم يحصلوا لهذه الحرب نتائج كبيره
كان في الرياض السيناتور الامريكي المعروف
نتحدث عن جاك سوليفان الرجل الثاني كما
يقال في واشنطن بعد الرئيس الامريكي كرئيس
المجلس الامن القومي هناك ايضا زياره
متوقعه ومجدوله ربما لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي نهايه هذا الشهر الى الرياض
وكاننا امام حاله
انزال الدبلوماسي امريكي مكثف على
السعوديه في هذا التوقيت هذا التوقيت
دكتور فليعني انه اشنطن بالفعل بدات تتفهم
المتغيرات في المنطقه والتغيرات السياسيه
السعوديه الان بشكل
يعني اهميتها الاقتصاد الجغرافي الثقل
المنطقه ام انه
يعني هي ورقه تستفيد منها في الانتخابات
القادمه يعني لم تحدثنا عن التوقيت
دون الشات موضوع الانتخابات دائما يستفيد
من اي تحرك خارجي كل رئيس وكل رئيس معارضه
يستعمل الزيارات او العلاقات لهذا الموضوع
ولكن الاساس هنا انا اسميه يعني حج سياسي
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه لانها هي
تغيرت اولا في الداخل الاصلاحات الهائله
ليس فقط هؤلاء السياسيين ولكن اطراف
الثقفيين اكاديميين ابحاث يذهبون الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ويعودون ويقولون
هذه ليست السعوديه التي كنا عرفناها في
الماضي شيء كبير حدث في السعوديه بدا يؤثر
على القيادات السياسيه من الحسبين تكلمتم
عن السنه
من
اجرام عمليا كان هو ينتقد الى القياده في
مرحله معينه ولكنه فهم ان التغييرات عميقه
جدا جاك سولف طبعا يبرهن انه الاولاد
الامريكيه الان جديه في اعاده علاقات اما
عن نجاح هذه المحاولات هذه يعني الحركات
السياسيه الدبلوماسيه يعود الى تفاهم بين
الاثنين يعني اليوم القياده السعوديه باتت
هي في موقع الاختيار الموقع بالتالي الان
كيف يمكن ان تفكر الرياض في الاختيار يعني
من ناحيه الضرورات الاستراتيجيه هناك
تفكير
بشانغهاي هناك تفكير ببريكس على سبيل
المثال اليوم الحديث عن اي تو يو تو يعني
كمنظمه تحاول امريكا الترويج الرياض كيف
تنظر الان الى
وكاننا في حاله اشبه من صراع او حرب بارده
ربما اذا جاز لنا وصفه بهذا الشكل هل تتفق
مع هذا الراي
حرب بارده بالنسبه للقياده السعوديه او
حتى للاداره الامريكيه هذه لعبه شطرنج
متحرك بسرعه جدا انا باعتقاد المملكه الان
هي في موقع انها تمد الجذور بكل الاتجاهات
هذا لم يكن في السابق انها في معسكر معين
الان اصبحت هي المعسكر ربما قد تنتقل الى
موقع الحكم ولذلك اكد على اهميه ما يجري
بالنسبه للسودان الرياض ربما بجده الان هي
التي تحاول ان تحل مشكله غير قادره ان
تحلها الرياض اقرب الى واقع المنطقه من
واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور وليد فارس
خبير السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
رابعه بعد قليل
وفد صينيين في السعوديه لبحث التعاون في
علوم الطاقه الذريه والعلوم الجيولوجيه
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه من الوكاله
الصينيه للطاقه الذريه زار المساحه
الجيولوجيه بهدف بحث سبل التعاون المشترك
في العلوم الجيولوجيه والطاقه الارضيه
البديله واستعرض الجانبان خلال الزياره
التعاون المشترك الذي يخدم البلدين في عده
مشاريع تتعلق بالعلوم الجيولوجيه وقاعده
البيانات الوطنيه الجيولوجيه وتم استعراض
الامكانات والخبرات التي يمتلكها الطرفان
والتي تضمن تحسين مخرجات العمل المشتركه
اعلنت وزاره الموارد البشريه السعوديه عن
بدء المرحله الثانيه من قرار المقابل على
العماله المنزليه بما يزيد عن اربعه
عاملين بدءا من يوم الخميس المقبل واوضحت
الوزاره ان المرحله الثانيه من القرار
التقضي بفرض مقابل مالي يصل الى
9600 ريال سنويا لكل عامل منزلي اضافي
يزيد على اربعه عاملين للفرد السعودي وعلى
عاملين للمقيم على ان يستثنى من القرار
الحالات الانسانيه التي تتطلب اكثر من
الحد المسموح له
تعاني المنطقه الشرقيه من نقص النحاد في
المشاريع السياحيه البحريه رغم امتلاكها
لشواطئ رمليه هي الاطول على سواحل الخليج
العربي
وسطات تساؤلات عن غياب المستثمرين عن
الاستثمار في المشاريع السياحيه البحريه
في المنطقه من جهه اخرى اعلنت امانه
المنطقه الشرقيه عن توقيع عقد استثماري
لمشروع تطوير منتجع بشاطئ نصف القمر اوضحت
الامانه ان المشوايه يشتمل على مركز او
على تطوير مراكز للترفيه والسياحه ومجموعه
من الخدمات المسانده كالمقاهي والمطاعم
وصحه عامه واطلالات مفتوحه متعدده
الاستخدامات
من الخضار ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي اهلا عبد الرحمن ما هي
حقيقه
الشواطئ في المنطقه الشرقيه من حيث
المشاريع السياحيه البحريه
خالد مع بدايه اقتراب موسم الصيف في كل
عام يتساءل الكثير من سكان المنطقه
الشرقيه لماذا هذه المنطقه تفتقر الى
المشاريع السياحيه البحريه النوعيه لا
سيما بان منطقه الشرقيه تضم اطول سواحل
بحريه على ضفاف الخليج العربي الى جانب
طبعا هناك الكثير من الرمال الشاطئيه في
غايه الجمال والروعه بدايه من نشاط العقير
في الجنوب وصولا الى مدينه الخفجي الحدود
الكويتيه السعوديه لكن هذه المشاريع لا
تزال يعني بطيئه الى حد ما بحسب اراء
المواطنين والمقيمين هنا في المنطقه
الشرقيه ولعل اخر المشاريع التي يعني
اثارت الاسئله حول هذا الموضوع هو تطوير
شاطئ نصف القمر
واعطاء هناك موقع لاحد المستثمرين الحديث
اكثر عن هذه الزوايا خارجه الي المهندس
عبد الله القومي وهو مدير المشاريع في
المدير الشؤون المشاريع والاداريه في
الفنيه والاداريه في اماكن الشرقيه مهندس
عبد الله نتكلم عن مشروع عنه مؤخرا في
شاطئ نصف القمر نتكلم عن تفاصيل ارقام حول
هذا المشروع
ومتوقع متى الانتهاء منه حياكم الله جميعا
متابعين ومستمعين ومشاهدين
في البدايه ولله الحمد تم توقيع مجموعه من
العقود الاستثماريه كما ذكرت في شاطئ نصف
القمر بمساحه تتجاوز الثلاثه مليون متر
مربع هي مشاريع سياحيه رياضيه ترفيهيه
تجاريه كما ذكرت لكم تجاوز مساحتها ثلاثه
مليون متر مربع يوجد فيها منتجعات سياحيه
بالاضافه الى الان في احد المواقع في
مدينه الخبر تم
تاجيره على احد المستثمرين بالضبط
كما ذكرت لكم منتجعات سياحيه بالاضافه الى
منطقه لحلبه السيارات ايضا من المشاريع
التي نفخر فيها في امانه المنطقه الشرقيه
هو مشروع الشاطئ المعياري اللي تتجاوز
مساحته اكثر من 100 الف متر مربع وهو
الشاطئ الاول من نوعه على توقع ينتهي من
المشروع هذا ان شاء الله خلال السنتين
الثلاثه القادمه راح يكون منتهي مساحته
كما ذكرت لكم 100 الف متر مربع هو يطبق
معايير العالم الازرق هي معايير بيئيه
مخصصه
التربه تربه الشاطئ ونوعيه المياه ايضا من
المشاريع المميزه اللي لازم نتطرق لها
ومشروع تطوير الواجهه البحريه الموجود في
كورنيش الخبر هو المشروع الاول من نوعه
بالتعاون مع مركز التخصيص حيث يوجد فيه
ايراد سنوي محدد بالاضافه الى نسبه مهندس
عبدالله تتفق مع وجهه النظر اللي تقول انه
فعلا منطقه شرقيه تفتقر الى المشاريع
السياحيه البحريه
خاصه مقارنه بالدول القريبه مثل البحرين
الامارات قطر نرى نرى في امانه المنطقه
الشرقيه ان المشاريع ونوعيه المشاريع في
المنطقه الشرقيه واعده ولله الحمد يوجد
اكثر من مشروع موجود على منصه فرص الان
على سبيل الذكر للحصر مشروع المدينه
الترفيهيه اللي موجود في النصف شاطئ نصف
القمر بمساحه تتجاوز ال180 الف متر مربع
ايضا من المشاريع التي لازم
التي لازم نتطرق لها هو مشروع النقل
البحري الذي عديد من المحافظات الموجوده
في المنطقه الشرقيه شمالا من الجبيل وصولا
الى شاطئ العقير هذا المشروع طرح في منصه
استثمر في السعوديه بالتعاون مع وزاره
الاستثمار وزاره الشؤون البلديه والقرويه
وهيئه تطوير المنطقه وهيئه الملكيه في
الجبيل وينبع بالاضافه الى امانه الاحساء
مرورا بعدد من المحافظات منها راس تنوره
والدمام والخبر والخفجي هذا المشروع الان
موجود على منصه فرص ومنصه استثمر في
السعوديه
شكرا جزيلا
وسؤال يعني اليوم
هل من المعقول انه توه مثلا
المستثمرين او التفتوا لاهميه هذه المنطقه
اهميه هذه السواحل افتقادها الى المشاريع
يعني مش اللي كان يمنعهم من الاقبال على
الاستثمار في سواحل طويله في منطقه مهمه
زي المنطقه
الشرقيه وهي مربحه مش كان الاسباب اللي
تمنعها وش اللي اختلف اليوم
نعم زميلي خالد يسال لماذا المستثمرين
كانوا مبتعدين عن مثل هذه المشاريع
السياحيه في المنطقه الشرقي وش اللي تغير
وخلوهم يقبلون الفتره القليل الماضيه
اعتقد وجود عديد من المحفزات التي قامت
فيها وزاره الشؤون البلديه والقرويه فعلى
سبيل الذكر للحصر يوجد نسبه اعفات 10% من
مده العقد فهذه احد الامتيازات التي قامت
فيها وزاره الشؤون البلديه والقرويه في
الامانه رصدت مؤخرا اقبال كبير من
المستثمرين تغير الوضع شوي فعلا
الاستثمارات الاستثمارات في القطاع البلدي
تطورت مؤخرا فعلى سبيل اللي ذكرته لكم 10%
نسبه اعفاءه على سبيل المثال لو عقدك 25
سنه فانت تتكلم عن سنتين ونص ما راح يكون
فيه اي قيمه مقابل التاجير بالاضافه الى
الامور التي تحسنت التاجير في القطاع
البلدي او الاستثمار في القطاع البلدي هي
تقليص نسبه الضمان البنكي سابقا كانت مئه
في المئه
والزملاء خان نتطلع الى الفرص الاستثماريه
بتحليل فني سابقا ننظر الى العرض المالي
فقط الان ننظر نحلل المشاريع تحليل فني
فالمشروع الذي يحصل على اعلى نتيجه في
عمليه التحليل الفني هو الذي يحصل على
الموقع في السابق كان الموضوع مختلف
المهندس عبدالله شكرا اعتقد خالد يعني
ربما الفتره المقبله نشهد العديد من
التطور والحراك في منطقه الشرقيه فيما
يتعلق بالمشاريع السياحيه البحريه
شكرا لكم
مشكله الاتصال الحكوميه الاخرى شكرا لك
يعطيك العافيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي مراسل
العربيه من شاطئ في مدينه الخبر
الاستزراعه السمكي مصطلح دارج خلال
السنوات القليله الماضيه الا ان السعوديه
عرفته قبل 37 عاما مع اصدار اول ترخيص يعد
الاستزراء السمكي احد القطاعات الجاذبه
للاستثمار والمهمه في دعم الامن الغذائي
لاي دوله زميل علي اللقبه يطلعنا على شيء
من هذه الصناعه في شرق السعوديه
[موسيقى]
37 عاما مرت على اول ترخيص للاستزراع
السمكي في السعوديه الذي اصدر عام
1986 في محافظه القطيف بعد كل هذه السنوات
تصل مشاريع الاستزراع السمكي الى 235
مشروعا في المياه البحريه والداخليه
والانظمه المغلقه منها ما يقارب 50 مشروعا
في المنطقه الشرقيه ياتم الاشراف على اكثر
من 50 مشروع استزراع سمكي على مستوى
المنطقه الشرقيه منها 15 مشروع استزراعه
سمكي ذو انتاج من 45 الى 60 طن شهريا يتم
انزاله جميعها في الاسواق المحليه يوجد
خمس مشاريع تعمل بالانظمه الحديثه المغلقه
وباقي المشاريع يتم انهاء اجراءاتها وسوف
يتم الانتاج عن قريب انتاج اكبر واستهلاك
مياه اقل هذا ما توفره فاطمه الحديثه في
مشاريع الاستزراع السمكي التي تضمن جوده
وزياده في كميات الانتاج بالنسبه للتراخيص
الاستزراء السمكي بالمنطقه يوجد نوعان من
التراخيص ترخيص بالانظمه المفتوحه وترخيص
بالانظمه المغلقه الان الوزاره في توجه
الى تراخيص الانظمه المطلقه
لتميز هذه الانظمه
انتاج ذو جوده عاليه من الاسماك وايضا
انتاج كثافات عاليه في الاحواض وايضا
تقليل الهدر من المياه حجم الانتاج السمكي
في السعوديه شاهد ارتفاعا بنهايه العام
الماضي ليصل الى 119 الف طن والهدف تحقيق
الاكتفاء الذاتي بنسبه تصل الى 59% من
الثروه السمكيه
من القطيف علي اللغبي العربيه
رابع ايضا مستمره فيها بعد قليل ضمن
مهرجان افلام سعوديه في المون يوثق رحله
الصحفي السعودي الراحل تركي سديري
اهلا بكم من جديد تفاعل واسع لقد صور حي
الكدوه في مكه المكرمه بعد الانتهاء من
اعمال ازاله العشوائيات تظهر الصور الحي
قبل وبعد اعمال الازاله والتطوير التي تقع
في المنطقه المركزيه وجاء تنفيذه مشروع
التطوير عشوائيات حي القدوه بعد استكمال
ما يخص اجراءات تثمين العقارات والتعويض
والحرص على توفير البدائل السكنيه
المناسبه للسكان الحاليين في المنطقه
المستهدفه واعطائهم الاولويه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
كيف ترى الصوره الان في حي الكدوه
بعد ازاله العشوائيات طبعا
نعم خالد اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه طبعا صوره مختلفه تماما عما كانت
عليه
الكدوه تحديدا او حي الكدوه سواء من خلال
العقارات الموجوده المنازل ايضا اشكالها
طريقه البناء كانت تبنى في هذه المنطقه
طبعا نتحدث عن سته الاف عقار كانت مبنيه
على هذه المنطقه بشكل غير منظم وغير مرتب
ايضا كانت هذه البنى او البنايات او ايضا
العقارات مبنيه على اسس غير ثابته من
ناحيه البناء التحتيه من صرف صحي من كذلك
مياه من ايضا التمديدات للكهرباء بسبب ان
هذه العقارات هي بنيت بشكل منظم من افراد
استخدموا هذا الحي كباقي الخمسه احياء
الاخرى التي يتم
من قبل هيئه تطوير مكه المكرمه لتطوير
العشوائيات سواء في حي الكدوه او كذلك
الاحياء الاربعه الاخرى طبعا قبل ما ابدا
عن هذا الحي ونتحدث عن هذا الحي لو نتخيل
الصوره التي كانت مبنيه في هذه المنطقه
الجبليه او العقارات التي كانت مبنيه في
هذه المنطقه الجبليه كانت بشكل بنايات على
شكل اشبه بالمدرجات طبعا تم
تطويرها بشكل كامل ايضا تم استكمال ما يخص
اجراءات التثمين العقارات وتعويض لاصحابها
كذلك توفير البدائل السكنيه المناسبه
للسكان الذين كانوا يغطنون في هذه المنطقه
طبعا عمليه التطوير جاءت خالد وكذلك
مشاهدي قناه العربيه بسبب اعاده تكوين
البيئه العمرانيه في هذه المناطق
العشوائيه سواء في حي القدوه او كذلك
المناطق الاخرى بسبب ايضا نشاه هذه
العقارات في مخططات وكذلك تقسيم اراضي
سابقه بدون اعتماد او بدون او تكون او
كانت عقارات غير مرخصه واستخدام هذه او
استخدام الافراد لها وبناءها بشكل عشوائي
في هذه المنطقه طبعا نتحدث عن هذه المنطقه
تحديدا الذي التي نشاهد صورها مساحتها
تتجاوز المليون متر مربع طبعا هناك كما
ذكرت الكدوه واحده من خمس احياء اخرى هي
تقوم هيئه تطوير او الهيئه الملكيه في
منطقه مكه المكرمه بتطويرها وهي بجانبها
طبعا حي الكدوه تحديدا لعله يكون هو
الموقع الاستراتيجي كونه قريب من الحرم
المكي وكذلك قريب من برج الساعه وكذلك
موقع الاستراتيجي من ناحيه ايضا انه محاط
بالط الرئيسيه والطرق الدائريه التي سوف
تساعد ايضا الحكومه السعوديه مستقبلا في
عمليه ايضا تنفيذ خطوطها من اجل المعتمرين
وكذلك في الحجاج في موسم الحج في بنايات
وفنادق او كذلك تطويرها كمساحه لكي تكون
مهيئه وجيده
لموسم الحج وكذلك العمره شكرا جزيلا لك من
مكه المكرمه من حي القدوه مراسل العربيه
نصفيا
مباشره لا لمتابعه هذه الصور المباشره من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم التي تظهرك
تصاعدا لاعمده الدخان
وتجدد ايضا للاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش
وقوات الدعم
السريع في ذلك رغم الاعلان عن هدى ايضا
بالاضافه كذلك الى المفاوضات والمحادثات
التي تجري بين طرفي النزاع الجيش وكذلك
الدعم السريع في جده في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
اذا هذه هي الصوره المباشره
لتجدد الاشتباكات في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم
خاصه بان هناك او قد شهدت هذه العاصمه
ربما هدوءا حذرا في هذا اليوم صباح هذا
اليوم
نستمع الان الى دوي انفجارات وكذلك اطلاق
لقذائف
في العاصمه السودانيه واعمده الدخان التي
تتصاعد في سماء الخرطوم
شاهد مهرجان وافلام السعوديه العرض الاول
للفيلم الوثائقي قصه ملك الصحافه الذي
يتناول سيره الصحفي السعودي الكبير الراحه
التركي اترك سديري رحمه الله قد تولى
سديري رئاسه التحرير صحيفه الرياض لاكثر
من 41 عاما
حضور كبير شهده العرض الاول للفيلم
الوثائقي قصه ملك الصحافه ضمن مهرجان
افلام السعوديه الفيلم وثق مسيره الصحفيه
السعوديه الشهير تركي السديري الذي تراس
صحيفه الرياض لاكثر من اربعه عقود ولدت
فكره الفيلم الاستاذ التركي السديري اولا
من شخص يعني صانع فيلم هو في الاساس من
مدرسه صحيفه الرياض التي كان يراسها
الاستاذ تركي السديري حينما تفرقت يعني
للعمل في السينما كان من اول المشاريع
اللي فكرت فيها هو يعني ان نصنع فيلم يوثق
سيره ملك الصحافه الاستاذ تركي الفيلم هو
في يمشي في خط زمني واحد يعني لينير اوكي
تحدث من بدايات
ولاده يعني من بدايه الى مراحل المر فيهم
الصحافه الرياضيه الى الصحافه الى الكتابه
الى مراحل يعني بيمر في مراحل وايضا
تحريات الوثائقيه تناول جوانب لاول مره
يسلط الضوء عليها في حياه الراحل تركي
السديري كالازمه الصحيه الذهنيه التي تعرض
لها اواخر حياته طبعا الفيلم بوضح لك اياه
ويقدم لا يقدم وجهه نظر فيه ويقدم حقائق
لكل الحق يتوجهت نظر في الراحه الله يرحمه
كما يشاء لكن الفيلم يعطيك حقيقه ولا
يعطيك وجهه نظر فيه ويعطيك معلومات مرت في
بدايه صحيت تحدياته في بدايه عمل الصحفي
في وسط عمله ثم النهايات ورحيله تفاعل
كبير لقاه فيلم قصه ملك الصحافه من حضور
مهرجان افلام السعوديه الذين اكدوا ان
شخصيه الراحل تركي الصديري تستحق مثل هذا
التقدير الفيلم جيد جدا يعني من ناحيه
المهنيه من ناحيه الموثوقيه من ناحيه
الاخراج الاض
واء اعتقد انه متكامل كان في خلق للازمه
خلق
لعلاقه تركي سديري مع الصحافه الورقيه خلق
لعلاقه مع الديجيتال ميديا خلق لحاله
مرضيه
اليوم فقط عرفها الجمهور يعني عبد الرحمن
العصيمي من الظهران العربيه
خلال العشرين عاما الماضيه حصلت تغيرات
مناخيه لم تسجل في السجلات المناخيه خالد
الزائك في تقويم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خلال العشرين سنه المنصمه تقريبا حصل
عندنا تغيرات مناخيه لم تكن مكتوبه في
السجلات المناخيه المدونه او محفوظه في
ذاكره كبار السن المرويه جريان متتالي
لاوديه لا تجري الا على فترات متباعده مثل
وادي الرمه جراها السنه مرتين ربيع على
نجد تهامه والمعروف انه اذا ربع التهامه
اجدبت نجد والعكس صحيح والعامه يقولون
ياويل نجد من الربيع تهامه هطولات مطريه
غزيره في عز القير كما حصل على سليل
والافلاك وحوطه بني تميم وليلى في العام
المنصرم هذه لم تكن ملاحظه علينا بس بل
العالم لاحظة هذا الشيء فبحر العرب لا
يولد الاعاصير الا على فترات متباعده
وخلال هذه الفتره بدا يولد عصارين في نفس
السنه 65
في ادفان اعصار اما سئمت ارتحالا ايها
ساري بل اكتفيت واضنان السرى وشكى قلبي
العناء ولكن
تلك اقداري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والعلماء حيال هذه التغيرات اقوال عده
اهمها من العلماء من قال ان هذه التغيرات
امور طبيعيه وهي تتبع نظام الدورات
المناخيه العظمى والتي مدتها 75 سنه فكلما
انتهى الدوره مناخيه عظمى منصمه وبدات
دوره مناخيه عظمى جديده فان السماء تتمخذ
لولاده هذه الفتره وهذا التمخض هو التغير
ومن العلماء من قال ان البشر هم اساس
البلاء بما احدثوه من ثوره صناعيه وما
ناتج عنها من ادخنه عملت على خلخله عناصر
المنظومه المناخيه ايضا ما فعلوه من
الاخلال في التوازن البيئي والحياه
الفطريه وهذا هو الذي سبب تغير ارضنا نقي
الفؤادك حيث شئت من الهوى ما الحب الا
للحبيب الاولي كم منزل في الارض يالفه
الفتى وحنينه ابدا لا
منزلي
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
نزاع السودان مستمر المحادثات في جده
مستمره والسعوديه تطلق حمله لغذي
ولي العهد السعوديه يلتقي مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي اليمن على راس الملفات
وفقا للبيت الابيض
غياب الاستثمارات عن شواطئ الشرقيه يثير
التساؤلات الشواطئ الاطول على سواحل
الخليج العربي
ومكه تتنفس مساحات كبيره من حي القدوه
تودع العشوائيات وتستعد لمراحل التطوير
ضمن مهرجان افلام السعوديه فيلم يوثق رحله
الصحفي السعوديه الكبير راح التركيز
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات